let's let's talk about the big galactic
things
and how we might be able to leverage
them to travel fast i know this is a
little bit science fiction but
you know uh ideas of wormholes and
yeah the ideas at the edge of
black holes that reveal to us that this
fabric of space-time
is uh could be messed with
yeah perhaps is that at all
an interesting thing for you uh i mean
in in
in looking out at the universe and
studying it as you have
is that also a possible like a dream for
you
that we might be able to find clues how
we can actually use it
to improve our transportation it's an
interesting thought i'm
certainly excited by the potential
physics that suggests this kind of
faster than light travel effectively or
you know
cutting the distance to make it very
very short through a wormhole or
something like that
possible no well you know call me not
very imaginative
but based on today's knowledge of
physics which i realize you know people
have gone down that rabbit hole and
you know a century ago lord kelvin one
of the greatest physicists of all time
said that
all of fundamental physics is done the
rest is just engineering and
guess what then came special relativity
quantum physics
general relativity how wrong he was so
let me not be another
lord kelvin on the other hand i think we
know a lot more now about what we know
and what we don't know and what the
physical limitations are
and to me most of these schemes if not
all of them
seem very far-fetched if not impossible
so travel through wormholes for example
you know it appears that for a
non-rotating black hole that's just
a complete no-go because the singularity
is a point-like singularity and you have
to
reach it to traverse the wormhole and
you get
squished by the singularity okay now for
a rotating black hole it turns out there
is a way to pass through the
event horizon the boundary of the black
hole and avoid the singularity
and go out the other side or even
traverse
the the doughnut hole like singularity
in the case of a rotating black hole
it's a ring singularity
so there's actually two theoretical ways
you could get through
a rotating black hole or a charged black
hole not that we expect charged black
holes to exist
in nature because they would quickly
bring in the opposite charge
so as to neutralize themselves but
rotating black holes definitely reality
we we now have good evidence for them
do they have traversable wormholes
probably not because it's still the case
that
when you go in you go in with so much
energy that it
it it either squeezes the wormhole shut
or you encounter a whole bunch of
incoming and outgoing energy
that vaporizes you it's called the mass
inflation instability and it just sort
of vaporizes you
nevertheless you know you could imagine
well you're in some vapor form but if
you make it through
maybe you could you know reform or
something
so it's still information yeah it's
still information it's scrambled
information but there's a way maybe of
bringing it back right
but then the thing that really bothers
me is that
as soon as you have this possibility of
traversal of a wormhole
you have to come to grips with a
fundamental problem and that is that
you could come back to your universe at
a time
prior to your leaving and you could
essentially prevent your grandparents
from ever meeting this is called the
grandfather paradox right
and if they never met and if your
parents were never born and if you were
never born
how would you have made the journey
to prevent the history
from allowing you to exist right it's
it's a it's a causal it's a violation of
causality
of cause and effect now physicists such
as myself take
causality violation very very seriously
we've never seen it you took a stand
yeah i mean you know
i mean it's one of these right back to
the future type movies right
and you have to work things out in such
a way that you don't
mess things up right some people say
that well you come back to the universe
but
you come back in such a way that you
cannot affect
your journey but then i mean that that
seems kind of
uh contrived to me or some say that you
end up in a different universe and this
also goes into the many different types
of the multiverse hypothesis and the
many worlds interpretation and all that
but again then it's not the universe
from which you
left right and you don't come back to
the universe from which you left and so
you're not really going back in time to
the same universe
and you're not even going forward in
time necessarily then to the same
universe right
you're ending up in some other universe
so
so you've you've what have you achieved
right
you traveled you traveled you uh
you ended up in a different place than
you started well
in more ways than one yeah and then
there's this idea um
the alcubierre drive where you warp
space-time in front of you so as to
greatly reduce the distance and you can
expand the space-time behind you
yes you're sort of riding a wave through
space-time
but the problem i see with that beyond
the practical difficulties and the
energy requirements and
by the way how do you get out of this
bubble through which you're
you know what riding this wave of space
time yeah miguel alcubierre
acknowledged all these things he said
this is purely theoretical fanciful and
all that but
a fundamental problem i see is that
you'd have to get
to those places in front of you so as to
change the shape of space-time
so as to make the journey quickly but
but to get there you got there in the
normal way
at a speed considerably less than that
of light
so in a sense you you haven't saved any
time right you might as well have just
taken that journey and gotten to where
you were going
yeah there's right you what have you
done you it's not like you snap your
fingers and say
okay let that space there be compressed
and then i'll make it over to alpha
centauri
in the next month you can't snap your
fingers and do that
yeah and but yeah and we're sort of
assuming that we can fix all the
biological stuff that
requires for humans to persist uh
persist through that whole process
because ultimately it might boil down to
just extending the life of the
of the human in some form whether it's
through the robot through the digital
form or through
or actually just figuring out
genetically how to live forever
because that's right that journey that
you mentioned the long journey
might be different if somehow
our understanding of genetics of our
understanding of our own biology yeah
all that kind of stuff would uh that's
another trajectory
if you could put us into some sort of
suspended animation you know hibernation
or something and
greatly increase the lifetime and so
these 10 000 generations i talked about
what do they care
it's just one generation and they're
asleep okay it's their
long nap so then you can do it it's
still not easy right because you've got
some big old huge colony and that
just through e equals mc squared right
that's a lot of mass that's a lot of
stuff to
um to accelerate the newtonian kinetic
energy is gigantic
right so you're still not home free but
at least you're not trying to do it in a
short amount of clock time right
which if you look at e equals m c
squared requires truly
unfathomable amounts of energy because
the energy
is sort of it's it's your rest mass m
naught c
squared divided by the square root of
one minus v squared over c
squared and if your listeners want to
just sort of stick into their pocket
calculator
as v over c approaches 1
that 1 over the square root of 1 minus v
squared over c squared approaches
infinity so if you wanted to do it in
zero
time you'd need an infinite amount of
energy that's basically why you can't
reach let alone exceed the speed of
light for a particle
moving through a pre-existing space
it's that it takes an infinite amount of
energy to do so
you